hallo was war das ich leute ich ich ich laber die ganze zeit mit euch ja ich rede
seit zehn minuten mit euch also fünf minuten ich rede seit fünf minuten mit
euch es muss keiner sagt was alter was ich dachte schon wieder und jemals ist
einer geschrieben habe ich schon wieder gedacht sollte beendet werden die fault
die weiß okay und warum warum warum er hat das jetzt die fault die weiß das ist
windows logik paints chammer massive paints champ ja also moment da habe ich
also dankeschön youtube 13 monate subscription dank ich das habe ich alle
schon erzählt und marze 20 90 habe ich alles schon gesagt so und
okay jetzt musst du doch mal von vorn anfangen also so was habe ich denn jetzt
alles erzählt die letzten fünf minuten ich habe mich schon gewundert warum
keiner was sagt denn das hat keiner gehört
jetzt ergibt das auch sinn will mir gleich ein arduino starter pack kaufen
hast du irgendeine empfehlung ja kein arduino kaufen sondern eles p32 was
ganz gutes einsteiger board findet neben den olarke us sind jetzt die neuen
mit display weil da kann man auch ein bisschen was ausgeben drauf auf dem
display das heißt sie enriched das jetzt schon mal fremd dieflix 12 oder 1 2 sair es 작업st Greenhrough 2014
ganz nett. Also ich muss sagen,
ich habe mir jetzt dieses Board hier bestellt
und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz gutes
Einsteiger-Board, weil
das hat ein Farbdisplay dabei.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz gut.
Viel zu teuer hier in Deutschland natürlich.
Aber ansonsten,
wo man
nichts falsch machen kann, ist
ein ESP32 NodeMCU.
Da kannst du gar nichts falsch machen.
Kann alles, hat alles,
super robust
und kann deutlich mehr
als ein Arduino.
Der Karlsson, 11 Monate,
Dankeschön.
Ja, ich habe die ganze Zeit erzählt,
erzählt und es kam nichts an.
Okay, also ich muss noch kurz in mich gehen.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben? Erstmal muss ich den Chat
wieder aufmachen, dass ich das nicht vergesse.
Okay, also.
Ja, übrigens,
FIPS 2, ich habe ganz am Anfang
gesagt, warum bist du so schnell da?
Du warst ja direkt am Start
und du hast, glaube ich, gar nichts gehört, weil du bist
da überhaupt nicht drauf eingestiegen.
Natürlich hat keiner was gehört.
Der Vetris, der ist auch am Start.
Ich habe, ich habe alles hier,
ich habe euch alle vorgelesen.
Keiner, keiner hat was gehört.
Genau, und Matze2090 zu der Frage, hast du nicht schon
einen Octopi laufen? Doch, habe ich.
Das hat nämlich auch keiner gehört.
Ich habe den 3D-Drucker ein bisschen umgerückt
und ein bisschen dabei
eins ab, ein Teil ab,
ein bisschen abgemacht und wieder zusammen gemacht.
Deswegen glaube ich, dass das Leveling
von der Unterlage voll im Arsch ist.
Und der Octopi
ist kaputt.
Octopi ist verreckt
vor einem halben Jahr oder so, vermute ich mal.
Ich habe das letztens erst gemerkt, weil ich habe lange
nichts mehr gedruckt. Ich habe das letztens erst
gemerkt, als ich
für jemand von YouTube
eine Halterung für eine GoPro ausdrucken
wollte, dass es nicht mehr geht.
Hast du einen Tipp, wie man über
mehrere Sub-Diagrapp
mir ist sowas eingefallen?
Gar nicht, einfach
crep-r.
Das ist schon eingebaut.
Einfach
crep-r für Recursive.
Ich zeige es dir, wir brauchen eh die
Lüftungskiste jetzt gleich.
Ja, der Easy-Killer
ist auch am Start.
Was ist das für ein Drucker? Ne, habe ich nicht gesagt, weil ich war
bis eben gemutet und ich habe es nicht
gecheckt.
Ich habe ein
Anycubic Mega
Ne, Anycubic
i3 heißt das Ding, glaube ich.
Mega S.
Das Teil habe ich. Das seht ihr auch gleich in der Webcam,
wenn ich das dann eingerichtet habe. So ein Teil hier.
Habe ich.
Das habe ich mir gekauft.
Wann war das? 2018 oder so?
Das ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Oder Anfang 2019, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Kennst du das Protokoll
HTCPC?
Nein.
HTCP kenne ich, aber
HTCP, das ist was zum
Das klingt wie irgendein G-Bait-Protokoll.
Irgendwie sowas wie
IMT-Port oder sowas.
Oder irgendwie
irgendwelche
G-Bait-Protokolle.
G-Bait-Geschichten.
Ja, ob ihr mich seht, ihr seht vielleicht
meinen Fuß, wenn ich vor dem 3D-Drucker stehe.
Da war es schon mit
Coffee-Pot gar nicht so verkehrt.
Genau, das Teil habe ich.
So, und
was habe ich vorhin auch erzählt? Genau!
Jetzt, wo ihr gesagt habt, ich bin
gemutet, da wollte ich eigentlich gerade sagen,
Leute, ich platze gleich, habe ich gesagt.
Leute, ich platze gleich.
Und dann habe ich PepoFat
eingeblendet. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, ich bin
wirklich gemutet. Und es hat
mich echt keiner gehört, weil spätestens
darauf hätte der Chat reagiert.
So, und wisst ihr, warum ich platze, Leute?
Nicht, weil ich so fett bin, sondern
weil mir juckt es so extrem
in den Fingern. Ich habe es gestern auf Twitter geschrieben.
Mir juckt es so extrem
in den Fingern, mir endlich
wieder einen neuen Rechner zu kaufen. Ich meine,
wann gab es das denn? Guckt mal hier.
Mein aktueller Rechner, der ist
drei Jahre, ziemlich genau, runden wir
mal auf, Oktober. Der ist ziemlich
genau drei Jahre alt.
Wie kann es sein,
dass ein drei Jahre alter Rechner
immer noch zum
oberen Ende gehört? Also ich
weiß, das ist jetzt wieder die absolute Boomer-Geschichte,
aber umgedreht, aber umgedreht Boomer,
weil
früher war der
Kram viel schneller kaputt.
Das hält übelst
lang, der Kram. Was ist da los?
Mittlerweile kommen öfters
Konsolen raus, als du dir einen neuen PC
kaufen musst. Das kann doch nicht
in der Ernstzeit, oder?
Wie geht das?
So was. Naja, zumindest
mir juckt es echt in den Fingern, was Neues
zu kaufen. Die Sache ist die,
ich kann mir nichts Neues kaufen. Das lohnt sich einfach
überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, guckt mal.
Ich hab mir den, ok,
das Ding war auch absolut top.
2017.
Eine 8700K, eine 1080T
und es gab nichts viel Besseres.
Es gab ja quasi nichts viel Besseres
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt. Ich hatte eine der ersten
8700K in Deutschland.
Also, das
ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das schlecht, aber
trotzdem. Wenn ich
mir zurückdenke zu Zeiten,
wo man noch
Schwanzvergleich mit Towergröße
gemacht hat,
so zu Zeiten, wo, sagen wir mal, Far Cry 1
aktuell war und solche Geschichten.
Alter, hast du den Rechner gekauft und
der war zwei Jahre später nicht einfach
nur schlecht, der war,
der war, wie sagen sie in Englisch
in Streaming, Dogshit. Der war
übelster Shit, der war übelster
Crap. Nach zwei Jahren konntest du den Rechner
quasi im hohen
Bogen vor dem Fenster in den Müll
schmeißen. Ob der dabei geputzt gegangen ist,
vollkommen egal.
Und jetzt habe ich mir einen
High-End Rechner gekauft und das Ding
ist nach drei Jahren, ich will
vielleicht nicht sagen, immer noch absolut
High-End, aber immer noch am
obersten Ende.
Klar, du könntest ein bisschen schnellere
CPU haben, du könntest ein bisschen schnellere
Grafikkarte haben, aber
das ist, bewegt sich alles so
im Bereich 10-15%, wenn es
hochkommt. Eine CPU,
in Spielen und in so normalen Anwendungen
schneller als ein 8700K, übertaktet
auf 5, beziehungsweise 5,1 Gigahertz,
das, da ist nix,
selbst die neueste Intel-CPU ist nicht
schneller. Also in Spielen
AMD eh nicht.
So, und deswegen, mir juckt es
so krass in den Finger, mir einen neuen Rechner zu
kaufen und ich weiß schon
genau, was ich mir kaufe. Ich hab's ja,
ich hab's ja gestern irgendwann mal auf Twitter, auf Twitter
sogar geschrieben. Ich weiß genau, was ich mir kaufe.
Ich hab schon, ich hab schon quasi die,
die Einkaufsliste,
hab ich schon vor mir, ja.
Aber, aber es kommt nix raus, ne.
Also, sobald, sobald
was Neues rauskommt, werd ich mir
als erstes, erstes kommt mir
hier nen Fractal
äh, äh, äh,
Define, Define 7.
Neues Gehäuse kommt an den Start
mit, äh, Glasplatte,
weil ich hatte jetzt schon nen Fractal Design
R4, R5, R6 und jetzt
kommt ein R7, äh, kein, das ist jetzt, sie haben das
eher weggelassen. Zeig mal deine
Hardware, das, da gibt's nicht sonderlich viel
zu zeigen. 8700K, 1080Ti,
Referenzdesign, äh, 32G RAM.
Das ist dann nix, nix, nix
Tolles und, und ne, ne M2 SSD.
So, und
äh,
das Ding hol ich mir als Gehäuse,
ist frisch rausgekommen. Dann
gibt's nen Ryzen
4950X,
also, wenn's den denn mal gibt,
ne, das ist dann wahrscheinlich ein 16
Kerner, 4950X,
vielleicht auch ein 4079X,
wobei,
eigentlich total sinnlos, aber 16
Kerne ist schon nice. Ne 3, äh,
ne 3080Ti,
aber es kommt ja nix, die kriegen's
nicht gebacken, die kriegen's diesmal
echt nicht, ich, ich bin hier kurz vorm Platzen und will
Geld ausgeben, ja, aber ich darf mein Geld
nicht ausgeben. Das ist das Schlechteste, was
du als Hersteller machen kannst, wenn die
Leute ihr Geld ausgeben wollen und sie können
dir ihr Geld nicht geben.
Ich will, ich will, ich will
euch mein Geld geben, aber ich kann euch mein Geld
nicht geben. Das ist doch was, was kein
Hersteller will, oder?
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Also meine Hardware-Liste, falls das irgendjemand
interessiert, ähm,
hier, 8700K,
eine Noctua-Lüfter,
32, 32 sind's mittlerweile,
32G RAM, irgendein komisches
XXHD Headshot Pro
360, tolles
Mainboard, äh, M2 SSD,
Fractal Design, oh, oh, sorry, ich hab Mist
erzählt, kein, äh, F5 ist es, R6
hatte ich gar nicht, äh,
Be Quiet und eine 8000, äh, 1080Ti.
Couch.
Excellent Couch. Und warum
ist sowas, hier, guck mal, es gibt sogar einen Geizhals-Link,
äh, warum ist sowas
nach,
nach, nach drei Jahren immer noch High-End?
Ich, ich versteh's nicht.
So, ähm,
so, und genau das, wie gesagt, genau das
werde ich mir kaufen,
sobald,
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Nein, hier ist nicht der Max.
Also, doch, schon, aber nicht, nicht da jetzt.
Äh,
boah, also, wie gesagt,
das Gehäuse, da freu ich mich schon drauf, das ist, äh,
logisches Upgrade von
dem, was ich jetzt hab, und
irgendwie, ich, ich, ich,
das geht mir, das geht mir voll, voll
auf den Keks, ne?
Wolltest du nicht vor einiger Zeit einen Ryzen kaufen? Doch!
Weil mir schon seit letztem Jahr
in den Finger juckt, ein neues System
zusammenzubauen, aber es ist total bescheuert,
einen Ryzen zu bauen, jetzt, so wie es ist.
Wenn ich mir einen Ryzen, äh,
3950, äh,
3059X kaufe, dann ist der
gar nicht mal schneller als
meiner jetzt, der hat einfach nur mehr Kerne.
Das ist ja nice to have,
aber wenn schon, dann will ich
auch in normalen Anwendungen ein bisschen
mehr Leistung haben, wenn ich, der, der Witz ist ja,
wenn ich mir jetzt, wenn ich mir
jetzt einen neuen Rechner kaufe, mit einem Ryzen
3950X, da hab ich mehr Kerne,
aber ich bin in Spielen sogar
langsamer als mein 3 Jahre
alte 8700K, der ein bisschen übertaktet ist.
So, das heißt,
wenn ich, wenn ich aufrüste, dann will
ich nicht so ein bisschen aufrüsten, so
zwischen, zwischen 0 und
10, maximal
15%, sondern das Ding
sollte schon immer 20, 30%
schneller sein.
So, reisen kann man nicht gescheit übertakten.
Der boostet sich ja selbst schon ganz gut.
So, und
das ist einfach Mist.
Und ich will ihm meine Kohle
geben, aber ich kann ihm meine. Kennst du kreativ?
Ich hab mal irgendwas, glaub ich, auf Twitter von so jemand
gelesen, der so hieß, ja.
So, und, ähm, die Sache,
ist die, sollten sie es jetzt schaffen,
mal bis Ende des Jahres,
und es ist ja never so lang, ich mein, wir haben schon
Mitte August, eine 4950X
und eine 3080Ti
rauszubringen, da hab ich mir das schon genau überlegt,
gucken wir mal, neun Monate, dankeschön,
excellent subscription,
äh, dann wird das Ganze
wahrscheinlich ungefähr so sein,
1000 Euro Grafikkarte, 1000 Euro
äh, GPU, so bisschen,
CPU ein bisschen weniger, Grafikkarte
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr bei Release, also sagen wir mal so über den Daumen
gepeilt, 1000 Euro Grafikkarte,
1000 Euro CPU und 1000 Euro für den Rest,
das heißt, dann kann ich endlich
wieder, ich, ich, ich warte schon drauf, ich bin
schon so heiß drauf, endlich mal neue Hardware
zusammenschrauben, der Rest wird,
der Rest wird so, das, das, die üblichen Verdächtigen,
irgendein BeQuiet-Netzteil, meine
10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte kommt rein, irgendein
fetter Noctua-Lüfter kommt wieder rein,
mit, mit Chromax, weil, weil,
weil,
weil auch immer, hat,
ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, warum man
seinen Lüfter irgendwie, ähm,
äh,
Blenden drauf machen sollte, weil da guckt man
eh nicht rein,
ergibt eigentlich wenig, wenig Sinn, aber
warum nicht, ja,
RGB-RAM, RGB-RAM,
natürlich, RGB-RAM
und
für mehr FPS, also RGB, ich nenne
den gleichen RAM, den ich jetzt hab, bloß ein bisschen schnellere
Variante davon, so, und ich hoffe,
dass es bis dahin endlich
eine
4 Terabyte Samsung
äh, M2 SSD
gibt, die gibt's nämlich noch nicht,
das Maximale, was Samsung aktuell hat,
ist, glaube, 2
Terabyte, ja,
und, und
ich hoffe, die, die schaffen's bis Ende des
Jahres eine 4 Terabyte zu haben, warum
brauchst du so viel, weil ich's haben will?
Außerdem kann man nie genug SSD-Speicher haben,
das ist ja schon mal klar, also, wenn man
eins nicht haben kann, dann ist es genug
SSD-Speicher, genau, um Sachen
zu speichern, äh,
2x2 Terabyte,
äh,
nö, da müsste ich ja
irgendwelche,
entweder irgendwelche RAID-Geschichten machen,
die ich garantiert mit Windows nicht mache,
ähm, oder
irgendwelche, die zusammenbandeln, oder eben
beides als unterschiedliche Festplatten verwenden, also,
lieber aufteilen,
damit nicht alles auf einer läuft, ne, ich kauf mir
eine 4 Terabyte SSD, das gerade alles auf einer ist,
warum soll ich das aufteilen,
wozu? Immer, immer
drauf, da lässt sich auch viel einfacher
Backup machen, einfach hier, flopp,
komprimiert, De-Duplication, fertig.
Mit ein paar Verzeichnissen,
das ist Excluded, nö.
Aber wenn's
das bis Ende des Jahres nicht gibt, dann, dann
hol ich mir halt eine 2 Terabyte, äh,
SSD, meinetwegen.
Übrigens, ich glaub, das mit 3.000 Euro
wird knapp, äh,
wenn ich mir überlege, was kosten, was kosten
so eine aktuelle 4 Terabyte Samsung,
äh,
das wird knapp,
das wird ganz schön knapp,
1.000 Euro CPU, 1.000 Euro
GPU, dann bleibt ja
500 Euro, okay, sagen wir mal,
die M2, sagen wir mal, die M2,
die M2 kostet dann wahrscheinlich sogar
eher, ich hoffe, 600 Euro,
ähm,
da bleiben noch 400 Euro übrig für Gehäuse,
Mainboard und, äh,
RAM, na, das, das, das reicht nicht mehr.
Das, das reicht nicht mehr, das, das reicht
nicht ganz. Es wird ein bisschen teurer wahrscheinlich.
Na, weil, da bleiben,
da bleiben noch 400 Euro übrig
für Netzteil,
Lüfter,
RGB-RAM,
Gehäuse,
das reicht nicht.
Das reicht nicht.
Warte mal, Geizhals,
was habe ich denn aktuell für, für einen RAM,
den will ich wieder haben. Ich will den gleichen RAM,
den ich jetzt habe, nur ein bisschen schneller.
Äh, ich habe Dings hier, guck da hier.
Ja,
excellent.
Brauche ich,
Ryzen, Ryzen mag schnell den RAM.
Sowas hier, so.
Und das Ganze dann
mal 4,
ach du Scheiße, ey,
okay, das wird, das wird doch ein bisschen teurer als 3.000, eher so 3.500.
Hast du gesehen, dass es gerade recht günstig 1TB PC-SSDs gibt? Nö.
Wo?
Ah, wozu?
Du meinst so eine hier, ne?
Keine, keine wirklich für PC-Dinge.
Also wie gesagt, ich kaufe mir den gleichen RAM, nur ein bisschen schneller.
Brauch
Dampf.
So, äh, das ist das Problem, warum ich kurz vorm Platzen bin.
Und ich war heute kurz davor, zu dieser Thematik schon ein YouTube-Video aufzunehmen,
äh,
weil ich gesagt habe, es kann nicht sein, es kann nicht sein,
dass ich seit drei Jahren Hardware am Start habe, nix da dran ändere,
und es beim Kauf
absolut high-end war,
und jetzt immer noch oberes Segment ist, nach drei Jahren.
Ich krieg's nicht, ja.
Was, Preise sinken, flotte SSD-Sel,
ich, okay, zeig her.
Na, das ist doch gut.
Dann gibt's dann vielleicht bis, wenn die das jetzt ablösen, dann gibt's dann vielleicht bis Ende des Jahres,
ähm,
ne, 4TB M2.
Was machst du mit der alten Hardware?
Wahrscheinlich das Gleiche, was ich mit der Hardware davor gemacht hab,
die Rechner einfach austauschen, also sprich, ähm, ich hab ja hier zwei Rechner nebeneinander stehen,
den aktuellen und den von davor,
und der eine ist, äh, Vorschau für Stream, und, und, mit nem zweiten Monitor dran,
Vorschau für Stream und paar Kleinigkeiten, und das andere ist halt Hauptrechner.
Und den werd ich einfach austauschen.
Und vielleicht mit dem noch älteren,
also der ist ja auch nicht schlecht, der ist ja auch in den vierkernen Dingsbums-Dings davor,
äh, da mach ich mir vielleicht irgendeine Linux-Kiste zum bisschen rumbasteln, auch im Stream.
So. So sieht's aus, okay.
Aber so viel zu meinen Hardware-Fantasien, was ich da kaufen will und was ich nicht kaufen will.
Kommen wir mal zum Thema 3D-Drucker.
Das ist nämlich die eigentliche Sache.
Übrigens, äh, ich mach mal mein...
Ah, das fung...
Das funktioniert übrigens mittlerweile.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr's auf Twitter gesehen habt.
Wer nicht auf Twitter am Start ist, äh,
wer gerne in die Streams guckt, das kann ich euch sagen, das lohnt sich insofern,
weil ich immer mal aktuelle Sachen zu Themen poste,
die wir auch gerade uns im Stream angucken.
Äh, hier. Da ist das...
Das fertige...
Das fertige Projekt.
Klimaanlagensteuerung.
Das ist das, was wir hier im Stream angefangen haben.
Das hier ist ein...
ESP32 mit einem Display.
So, den hatte ich noch.
Den hatte ich noch.
Der ist auf dem Abort.
Deswegen die Antenne.
Aber da ist ein Display drauf.
Das war in dem Fall ganz praktisch.
Äh, das da hinten ist der Temperatursensor.
Temperatur-Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Das ist die aktuelle Luftfeuchtigkeit, aktuelle Temperatur.
Und der Keks hält die Infrarot-LED,
die zur Klimaanlage zeigt,
dass das die Klimaanlage steuern kann.
So, ähm...
Und ich hab da noch den Knopf hier oben programmiert,
dass ich damit die Klimaanlage ein- und ausschalten kann.
Und das...
Und das ist übrigens der Grund,
warum ich heute anfange mit 3D-Drucker.
Das war der eigentliche Grund,
warum ich heute angefangen hab mit 3D-Drucker.
Weil ich, ähm...
nach schönen Gehäusen
für dieses Teil hier gesucht hab.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, oh fuck.
Mein 3D-Drucker geht ja gerade gar nicht.
Was kostet so ein Sensor?
Äh, du meinst hier so Luftfeucht...
3,50 bei AliExpress oder so?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
1,68.
Ich bin nicht von China-Preisen ausgegangen.
1,68 von wegen 5 Euro.
Okay, guck mal, wenn du neu bist,
musst du gar nichts dafür bezahlen.
Da kannst du hier Infinite-Money-Loop machen.
Kriegst du...
Guck mal, du kriegst 1,70 erstattet.
Von den 1,70 machst du dir einen neuen Account
und kaufst wieder sowas, so einen Sensor.
Und dann kriegst du es wieder erstattet.
Und dann kaufst du dir wieder einen Sensor.
Und dann kriegst du es wieder erstattet und davon kaufst du dir den nächsten Sensor.
Und dann hast du Infinite-Money-Loop.
Easy Money.
Ja, aber bei AliExpress,
der Kram ist wirklich billig.
Ähm, genau.
Und das war eigentlich auch der Stein des Anstoßes hier.
Dass ich...
Ja, Versand. Genau zum Thema Versand
muss ich noch was sagen.
Ich muss mal irgendwo einen Sensor aufmachen, den ich auch bestellen darf
als Neukunde.
Ähm, Versand muss ich sagen...
Ich würd mir eh nie
einen bestellen. Nie einen.
Also der Versand aus China ist eh
billiger als der Versand aus Deutschland.
Das ist ja eh schon irgendwie ein bisschen lächerlich.
Aber es ist halt so.
Wahrscheinlich subventionieren wir das irgendwie. Und die Chinesen auch noch.
Zumindest deswegen würd ich immer so einen 10er-Pack dann nehmen.
Klar, so.
Braucht man immer mal.
10er-Pack, dann bezahlst du...
Kannst du dir noch ausgucken, aber am besten...
Das ist schon ganz gutes Shipping.
Das ist sogar relativ schnell.
Das braucht ungefähr einen Monat.
Meistens ist es schneller.
Ähm...
So, dann bist du am Ende
bei...
16 Euro.
2 Euro Versand.
18 Euro.
Und du bezahlst für einen Sensor hier schon...
Du bezahlst für einen Sensor...
Ne, ne, ne. Das ist Schwachsinn.
Achso, das sind 3 Stück.
14 durch 3.
Exzellent. 4,6.
Also, viel zu teuer in Deutschland.
Der Kram. Guck mal.
China. China-Kram.
So, und das ist auch
der Anstoß gewesen, warum ich heute mit 3D-Drucker-Kram
angefangen habe. Ja, aber jetzt
mal zum Thema 3D-Drucker.
Jo, was geht? Wir haben noch nicht groß...
Gerade nicht viel. Wir haben gerade noch nicht so großartig angefangen.
So, ähm...
Sind 3D-Drucker
immer noch so teuer? Ne, es geht.
Ich bin jetzt aktuell nicht mehr ganz
so drin, was das Thema 3D-Drucker angeht,
weil ich habe mir den gekauft und bin damit jetzt eigentlich ganz
zufrieden. Ähm...
Der hier ist relativ günstig.
Der war damals auch schon relativ günstig.
Aber davon gibt es, glaube ich, einen neuen.
Äh, was aktuell relativ
angesagt ist bei 3D-Drucker ist
ein Side... Oh, fuck. Wie hieß das Ding?
Side... Sidewinder
X1 war das der?
Der ist aktuell relativ
angesagt. Das habe ich in, in, in einem
3D-Drucker-Forum gelesen. Keine Ahnung, ob das
wirklich stimmt. Also, ich kann da keine Empfehlung
aussprechen, aber der ist aktuell auch noch relativ
angesagt. Dann, äh, ganz
einsteigermäßig ist
das Ding. Das ist auch relativ
beliebt. Das ist noch mal, noch mal eine ganze Ecke
billiger. Ähm,
das geht so 150 Euro los. Und wer,
und wer was richtig Cooles haben will, da war ich
damals auch kurz davor, mir einen zu kaufen, aber ich wollte nicht
1000 Euro ausgeben, war, ähm...
Ich weiß gar nicht
mal, welcher es war von dem...
Ich glaub, der?
Ich bin mir jetzt aber nicht ganz sicher.
Ich, also, wenn's,
wenn's der war, dann ist
der richtig gut. Der hat, der, aber
sag mal so, bei 3D-Druckern macht's, ähm,
der Preis schon ein bisschen
aus. Also, ähm,
vor allem halt auch, was Komfortfunktionen
angeht. Zum Beispiel,
bei dem, bei meinem,
aber wie gesagt, alles ein bisschen mit Vorsicht
zu genießen, ich bin nicht der wahnsinnige 3D-Drucker-Profi,
ne? Ähm, bei meinem
ist es so, der,
hier das Druckbett,
kann die Auflösung mal hochgehen, das Druckbett,
wenn das schräg ist, und das
werden wir auch gleich mal ausprobieren,
ähm, das, da hast du hier unten so Schrauben,
das musst du selbst einstellen,
und musst selbst kalibrieren. So,
und wenn du hier so einen Prusa,
äh, Prusa, wie auch immer man
das genau ausspricht, holst, der hat zum Beispiel
Sensoren, die vorher checken,
wie dein, ähm,
Druckbett ausgerichtet ist, und kalibriert
sich selbst. Also, du, du hast bei
3D-Druckern, der Preis macht da viele
Komfortfunktionen aus, hier soll wohl
die Firmware auch richtig gut sein, der Support
auch richtig gut sein, und generell die Qualität
von dem Ding richtig gut sein. Also, das ist so wohl,
ist, ist von der Weile mal so als
in Anführungszeichen Geheimtipp gestartet,
mittlerweile dürfte das einer der beliebtesten 3D-Drucker
überhaupt sein. Ähm,
ja, das, das weiß ich aktuell
grad zum Thema 3D,
die Musik geht mir voll auf den
Sack.
Ah.
Gut, ähm, also kommen wir mal zum Thema 3D-Drucker.
Die Sache ist die, wenn man,
also, denn, wie gesagt, den hab ich seit
entweder Anfang 2019 oder, oder 2018,
muss ich mal kurz, ich poste
noch alles mögliche auf Twitter.
Ich, ich poste noch alles mögliche auf Twitter.
Twitter ist so
Lebenshistory, was ist das denn?
What the?
Ist doch gar nicht Twitter. Achso, das war
auf der Gamescom. Ähm...
Hat jemand
einen guten Tipp für den Eintrag? Okay, dann hab ich
mir Anfang 2019 gekauft, den 3D-Drucker.
Wenn ich
hier nach einem guten Einsteiger, dann hab ich mir das
glaub ich am gleichen Tag noch bestellt.
Anycubic...
Ja, also irgendwie, also
ich hab das ungefähr in einem Jahr, das Ding. Und ich
hab damit halt nicht so viel gedruckt. Ich hab mir das
hauptsächlich gekauft, um Gehäuse zu drucken für
meinen Bastelkram.
Hast du den i3 auch schon umgebaut?
Äh, was meinst du genau?
Also, was ich gemacht hab, ist...
Also, ich hab ja einen i3 Mega S, das ist ja schon
die etwas neuere Variante. Ähm...
Was ich gemacht hab, ist, ich hab
eigentlich nur
eine Kamera-Halterung dran gemacht
und, äh,
einen LED-Ring an
den Lüfter-Stromanschluss,
dass das Ding schön beleuchtet ist,
wenn er druckt. Ansonsten...
Also, ich hab weder den Motor umgebaut,
noch hab ich irgendwelche
Treiber-Geschichten umgebaut, noch hab ich irgendwelche
Firmware-Flash-Geschichten gemacht
oder so.
Gar nix. Ich wollte jetzt da eigentlich auch
gar nicht so viel basteln, sondern bloß ab und zu mal ein Gehäuse
drucken, ja. So.
Und, äh, was wir heute machen, ist folgendes.
Wenn man so einen 3D-Drucker hat...
Leute, ich muss andere Musik anmachen.
Das nervt mich hier. Das ist zu...
...zu
dringlich, irgendwie.
Äh, die Kamera, die ist
hier oben dran.
Also, ich hab zwei Varianten für die Kamera.
Aktuell hab ich sie hier oben dran. Die guckt von oben
auf das Druckband. Und ich hab mir eine
Halterung ausgedruckt, dass man
die Kamera hier vorne dran stecken kann. Das ist eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Okay, das kann ich mir
jetzt schon eher geben.
Bisschen laut, hä?
Kann sich weder der entscheiden.
Okay.
Ähm, so. Das bisschen doofe
bei 3D-Drucker ist, es gibt
welche, die haben einen eingebauten Webserver und so.
Da ist das alles nicht so wild.
Aber bei den meisten 3D-Druckern
ist es halt so, du kannst
die, äh, Drucke dort nur
per SD-Karte dran machen oder mit nem Laptop
am USB. Das ist alles ein bisschen doof.
So, und deswegen gibt es dieses
Projekt hier. Octoprint.
Würdest du dir den 3D-Drucker nochmal kaufen? Ja.
Ich find den Preis-Leistung... Also,
preis-leistungsmäßig ist das Ding wirklich top.
Ich kann dir allerdings nicht sagen, ob das noch das
aktuelle Modell ist. Wir können ja mal gucken, ob die
noch, ob die noch
was Neueres mittlerweile haben.
In der Richtung. Ah, guck mal,
anscheinend gibt es ein Mega-X, ein Mega-Pro,
ein Mega-S.
Ah, okay, der ist wohl immer noch
halbwegs aktuell. Der ist wahrscheinlich
größer. Das hier ist, glaube ich, einfach ein
S++ ein bisschen größer, vermute ich
mal. Äh, ja, aber den würde ich wieder
kaufen. Also, Chat, ich weiß nicht, wer von euch damit
auch Erfahrung hat, könnt ihr ihm ja, ähm,
mal was zu
schreiben. Aber ich find den Preis-Leistungs-
mäßig wirklich gut.
Gibt's auch ein Monka-S?
Das wär eigentlich mal ein richtig guter 3D-Drucker-Name.
Ja.
So, also,
fangen wir an. Wie gesagt, normalerweise
muss man da per SD-Karte dran oder
per USB. Und es gibt ein schönes
Projekt, das nennt sich Octoprint.
Das kann man auf dem Raspberry Pi
installieren. Und dann kann man über
den Raspberry Pi 3D-Drucke hochladen
und drucken lassen und, und Zustand
gucken und ein Webcam zum Überprüfen.
Es gibt richtig coole Plugins.
Hab ich gesehen, ähm,
also, ich hab ja das letzte,
das letzte Mal, wo ich Octoprint verwendet hab, hab ich ganz klar
sich ohne jegliche Plugins verwendet. Aber
es sind mir ein paar Sachen auf den Keks gegangen, wo es
wohl recht coole Plugins gibt. Zum Beispiel,
dass man eine Anzeige auf dem 3D-Drucker-Display
hat, wie lang es noch dauert, dass
man die Druckzeit besser berechnen kann,
dass man eine Sidebar mit der Webcam
hat, dass man bessere Timelapses
machen kann, dass man, äh,
Fail-Drucks erkennen kann
und, und solche, solche Geschichten.
Ja. Da gibt's, da gibt's,
äh, jede Menge, jede Menge Sachen.
Das wollte ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, weil,
äh, ich will mir wieder ein paar Gehäuse
drucken. Und nachdem mein aktueller, äh,
Octopi kaputt ist, machen wir das Ganze
jetzt mal. So, ähm,
dazu gehen wir jetzt nämlich mal auf GitHub, gehen wir hier in die
VM.
Machen wir ganze Tabs hier mal wieder zu.
Alter, wie viele Tabs
haben wir hier auf, äh?
Ich mach mal den Browser zu, dass er ein bisschen RAM freigibt.
Man weiß ja nie.
Aber ja, ist mal alles,
alles dicht. 16 Tage.
Lul. Äh, GitHub,
Octopi.
Ah. Also,
wie gesagt, es gibt Octoprint und es gibt
Octopi. Das eine ist die
Software an sich, die man später verwendet.
Octopi ist nix anderes, wie
nen Raspbian Image, was einer schon fertig
gebaut hat. Was aber
einfacher, was die Sache aber einfacher macht.
Ja. Ist ja, äh, keine Ahnung.
Deswegen hab ich das auch aus. Also ich mach, ich,
ich hab keine Fade-Animation. Viel besser,
wenn man so die Desktops umschalten kann.
Und man schickt ja hin.
Ich mach den Hintergrund diesmal.
Übrigens, für den Hintergrund ist
das einzige, was ich bei Bing verwende.
Ein Bing.
Aber Bing hat nen schönen, äh,
äh, Daily Image
Algorithmus.
So. Jetzt laden wir uns den Kram mal runter.
Ich schnapp mir mal
einen,
einen, wo ist er denn?
Micro SD-Kartenleser?
Wo hab ich? Ah, hier.
Da ist einer. Und da brauch ich noch ne
Micro SD-Karte.
Und dann flashen wir das Ganze mal. Und das erste,
was wir machen werden ist,
die Webcam einschalten,
dass ihr auch was seht und ich auch
was sehe und ich nicht laufend rüber rennen muss.
Bing war doch die Pornosuchmaschine.
War nicht Bing.
Es war,
keine Ahnung, was da alles gibt.
Ich glaube, glaube da gibt's bessere
Sachen als Bing.
Ich könnt ja mal im
Recording-Ordner gucken, ob ich da ne
Pornosuchmaschine finde.
Das hat jetzt keiner verstanden,
außer die, die dabei waren.
Ähm, so. Also.
Wir haben den Kram jetzt runtergeladen.
Starten wir mal ne Runde
Edger. Flash vom
File. Äh.
Downloads. Waren wir den Kram
hier mal hin? Hallo?
Downloads. Äh. Octopie.
Buster Light.
Oh. Moment.
Der ist noch gar nicht fertig mit runden.
War zu schnell. Vodafone
kommt nicht mit. Ach, du meinst
in Windows? Äh.
Ja.
Kann man das ausschalten? Wusste ich gar nicht.
So. Flash vom
File. Octopie Light. Jetzt dürfen
wir. Select Target.
Äh.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Auf die Systemplatte will ich nicht flashen.
Ah, hier. Yes.
So.
Jetzt aber. Select Target.
32G Samsung
SSD.
Select Flash.
Gut. Hauen wir das mal auf die MicroSD
gerade drauf. Und wie gesagt, sobald wir das drüben
äh. Sobald ich das drüben im Raspberry Pi
reingesteckt hab, werd ich
die Webcam als erstes anmachen.
Dann gucken wir gleich mal, ob man da gescheit
was sieht drinnen. So.
Ähm. So. Und Plugins.
Musst du mal gucken. Ich hab mir ein paar. Ich hab mir ein paar
Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Äh. Kann man hier so. Zum Beispiel.
Was ich ganz praktisch fand, war
diese Geschichte.
Ähm. Dass man seine Webcam an der Seite
sieht. Ähm.
Dann, was auch noch richtig, richtig
gut ausgesehen hat, ist
hier äh. Print
Time.
Print Time Genius. Sah auch ziemlich praktisch
aus. Dass man äh.
Genauer berechnen kann.
Wie die Druckzeit
ist. Was richtig gut ist,
ist.
Das wollte ich schon die ganze Zeit mal.
Die ganze Zeit mal ausprobieren. Allerdings
weiß ich nicht, ob das kostenlos ist. Aber die Idee ist,
richtig gut. Und zwar.
Ähm.
Der erkennt.
Der erkennt quasi.
Per. Per.
KI. Na aber nicht KI.
Das ist irgendeine OpenVC Geschichte.
Äh. Der erkennt per
Algorithmus, wenn der 3D Drucker anfängt
Mist zu drucken. Guckt hier.
Was praktisch ist. Weil wenn der
erkennt, dass der 3D Drucker
anfängt Mist zu drucken.
Vielleicht sieht man das jetzt hier auch nochmal.
Dann bricht er nicht ab oder so.
Sondern hält an. Das ist ziemlich
praktisch. Weil wenn sich das Ding mal
irrt. Kann man einfach drauf gucken.
Und sagen. Äh. Momente mal.
Mach weiter.
Aber wenn der wirklich
Failed ist.
Wie der jetzt hier. Ja.
Auch meint, dass das irgendwie gefailt.
Gefailt hat. Äh.
Dann spart man einfach Material.
Weil der muss ja nicht weiter
drucken, wenn der Druck hier voll am abkacken ist.
...
Twitterplugidee. Mein 3D Drucker muss nicht twittern.
So.
Ich geh dann klein. Achso. Oh. Äh. Moment. Wie mach ich denn
das jetzt? Leute. Ich muss meine
WLAN Config anpassen. Ohne das ihr es seht.
Wie machen wir denn das jetzt?
Also es ist nicht so schlimm.
Ich hab ja eh nen extra WLAN für Streams.
Aber ich will euch das Passwort
trotzdem nicht verraten.
Ich muss. Ich muss euch. Ich muss die Kamera ausschalten.
So. Ähm.
Gut. So. Jetzt haben wir die ganzen
Kram geflasht. Was wir jetzt machen.
Muss ist. Und das muss man übrigens bei jeder
Raspberry Pi Installation machen.
Beziehungsweise Raspberry Pi
ähm. Ähm. Raspbian Installation machen.
Man muss sich die
ähm. Die Boot Partition
mal mounten.
Und dort WLAN Config
anlegen.
So. Ich mach euch jetzt mal kurz
äh. Ich mach euch mal kurz
aus. Ich überlass euch dem
Chat.
Und äh. Ich trag mal meine
WLAN Daten ein.
Ohne das ihr die seht.
Und dann hoff ich da ich
mich nicht verschreibe. Weil sonst ist es im Clipboard Manager
drin.
Ihr seht nicht mein Passwort. Ich habs aus.
So. Also mit
mit allem lasse ich mich auch nicht debaten.
Ok. Jetzt muss ich noch das
Land einstellen.
Nein. Wir sind nicht France.
Wir sind DE.
So. Sehr schön.
Fertig.
Ich mach euch wieder an.
Da sind wir. So.
Jetzt habe ich meine WLAN Credentials
eingegeben. Sync.
Unmount.
Und jetzt gehe ich rüber
und stöpsel das ganze in Raspberry Pi rein.
Land liegt.
OMG. Gut. Ähm.
Dann. Dass ihr was
zu tun habt.
Ich bin in. Keine Ahnung.
Eine Minute wieder da. Ich muss bloß die SD Karte
rein stöpseln. Das ist ja. Also ich hab den 3D
Drucker hier stehen.
Ich hab den 3D Drucker
drüben in so einem Abstellraum stehen.
Weil das geht einem ja voll auf den Sack.
Wenn das Ding da rumfährt und
pustet und macht.
Ja SSH ist an.
So.
Also. Wieder am Start.
Jetzt gucken wir mal was das Ding für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Ich hab geschaut was der alte hatte.
Also der müsste eigentlich
die hier bekommen.
Der müsste eigentlich die bekommen.
Weil der hatte die alte. Der hatte die
alte IP zumindest. Aber mal schauen.
Nebenbei auf meinem. Ah da ist er.
Ok. Wunderbar. Muss ich mich doch nicht auf meinem Router einloggen.
So.
SSH. Pi add.
Yes. Raspberry.
Und.
Einloggen please.
Einloggen. Einloggen.
Slowchamp. Da sind wir.
Perfekt.
Hat funktioniert.
Max was ist denn Octopi?
Das ist ne.
Raspberry Pi Distribution.
Eigentlich ist es ein Raspbian plus Zusatzsoftware.
Ist nichts großartiges. Eigenes.
Für einen 3D Drucker.
Wo man 3D Drucker Aufträge und sowas
besser mitmanagen kann.
Und auch ne Webcam an 3D Drucker machen und sowas.
So.
Und jetzt sollen wir.
Das da oben funktioniert garantiert nicht.
Jetzt sollen wir hier auf die
Adresse. Wir gehen mal hier im Browser dahin.
So.
Und jetzt sollte da wenn wir Glück haben
ein Octopi aufgehen.
Oder auch nicht.
Wir gucken mal was das Ding für ne Auslastung hat.
Ok der ist noch ein bisschen beschäftigt.
Da können wir bei der Gelegenheit gerade mal
die wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt
installieren.
Nen Wim. Nen Wim.
Nen T-Max. Nen D-Stat.
Nen HTOP und.
Dass ich den einfach neu starte.
Was macht D-Stat zeige ich dir gleich.
Das ist nen.
Das ist irgendein Python Programm.
Wo man die Auslastung vom Rechner
I-O mäßig sich angucken kann.
Ist finde ich ganz praktisch.
Da sieht man Netzwerkverkehr
und I-O auf die Platte und sowas.
Ich machs mal kurz an.
So hast du hier geguckt. Da siehst du hier
Read Write Platte
CPU so.
Also eigentlich guckt man das siehst du nur für die zwei Sachen hier an.
Finde ich ist die einfachste Übersicht.
Ich meine es kann auch ein bisschen mehr mit Optionen ab.
So. Da sind wir.
Excellent.
Hello. Installing Octopi.
Wizard. Jawoll.
Access Control.
Wer braucht Access Control.
Erstmal ausschalten.
So. Mal davon abgesehen.
Das ist nicht verkehrt. Das kann man durchaus ausschalten.
Das Ding ist eh nur intern bei mir
erreichbar.
Hast du schon mal einen Bash Top beziehungsweise
PB Byte Top. Ne habe ich nicht getestet.
Das liegt aber hauptsächlich daran.
Weil das nicht in den Repos drinne ist.
Wenn das in den Repos drinne wäre.
Gucken wir mal.
Da könnte man das tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Ansonsten
hat man nichts davon.
Wenn es tolle neue Software gibt.
Gerade so System Auslastungsgeschichten.
Wenn man die nicht auf Remote System verwenden kann.
Weil die nicht in den Repos drin sind.
Ja.
So fancy das auch aussehen mag.
Und irgendwie hat der Probleme mit Unicode Zeichen hier gerade.
Fehlt mir wahrscheinlich
irgendeine Schriftart.
So fancy das ist. Solange ich das nicht auf dem Server verwenden kann.
Das ist irgendwie reichlich sinnlos.
Weil meine lokale Auslastung die gucke ich mir sehr selten an.
Was für eine Schriftart muss ich installieren.
Das der Kram funktioniert.
Ich mein.
Ich habe sogar.
Ich habe sogar eine.
Ich habe sogar eine Emoji Schriftart installiert.
Das ich Emojis im Terminal habe.
Ne und das andere habe ich auch noch nicht probiert.
Aber das gibt es gar nicht.
Das gibt es nur im User Repos.
Also wie gesagt.
Solange das nicht in den Repos bei großen Distributionen dabei ist.
Bringen es diese Tools alle nicht.
So schön sie sind.
Aber wann will ich mir denn mal.
Meine lokale Auslastung angucken.
Ich will mir Remote System Auslastung und I.O angucken.
Wenn die Probleme haben.
So.
Hat Octopie fertig.
Ne hat nicht fertig.
Also wir Disable Access Control.
Übrigens.
Nehmt das ernst was die hier schreiben.
Sollte das wirklich.
Irgendwie von außen erreichbar sein.
Das auf gar keinen Fall ausschalten.
Weil sonst hat jeder aus dem Internet Zugriff auf euren 3D Drucker.
Also nicht nur schlimm genug.
Das der Zugriff auf eine Linux Kiste.
Der dann quasi hat.
Von euch.
Und damit auch schon genug anstellen kann.
Er hat auch noch Zugriff auf euren 3D Drucker.
Im Zweifelsfall fackelt noch irgendeiner euer Haus ab.
Aus dem Internet raus.
Irgendwelche krassen Hexer aus Bangladesch.
Fragt mich nicht.
Also.
Macht das auf gar keinen Fall.
Bei mir ist das kein Problem.
Meine Kiste ist nicht im Internet erreichbar.
Nein wir wollen nichts.
Keine Daten tracken.
Keine Daten checken.
Kann er machen.
Blacklist das machen wir an.
Das war wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Für irgendwelche Plugins die Probleme machen.
Das er die erst gar nicht anzeigt.
So und jetzt muss ich meinen Drucker einrichten.
Und zwar ich hab ein Anycubic.
Ich kann das.
Wir machen Google Auto Vervollständigung.
Anycubic i3 Mega S.
Jetzt muss man einstellen.
Was das Ding für Abmaße hat.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Deswegen muss ich nachgucken.
Gibt es auch hier bestimmt irgendwelche.
Anleitungen.
Also was muss man hier einstellen.
210 210
Oh.
21cm
So der soll unten links anfangen.
Heat Chamber.
Sieht eigentlich gut aus.
Achsen.
So stellt der hier ein.
Das ist Default.
Durchmesser von.
Da wo das.
3D Druckzeug raus kommt.
4mm das passt.
Glaube ich.
Passt das.
0,4
Und ein Extruder.
Wo ich bis heute nicht genau weiß was der Extruder ist.
So.
Next.
Ja ja. Finish.
Reload.
Excellent.
Ist der E3 und der E3 Mega das gleiche von den Maßen?
Ja.
Soweit ich weiß schon.
Der Mega S hat ein paar kleine Upgrades.
Die man aber auch ziemlich einfach an dem E3 Mega nachrüsten kann.
So.
Update Available.
Update Now.
Ja mach mal.
In der Zwischenzeit.
Schalten wir mal die Kamera ein.
Äh.
Die müssen wir wahrscheinlich gar nicht einschalten.
Das macht er wahrscheinlich selbst.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal ob die Kamera geht gleich.
Wenn er die Absätze zählt.
Wir gucken gleich ob die Kamera geht.
Vielleicht muss ich gar nichts großartiges einstellen.
Dass die Kamera funktioniert.
Monka Leak.
Ja ihr seht dann den 3D Drucker in der Abstellkammer.
Wahnsinn.
Huge High Octane Leak.
Macht der da 3 Stunden ein Update?
Aber ist das noch Python 2?
Haben die vor das zu upgraden?
Oh. Hier guck mal da.
Ach da geht es um Plugins.
Hier sieht anscheinend auch so eine Mischung aus.
Ähm.
Äh die sind wahrscheinlich so eine Mischung.
Aus Python 2 und Python 3.
Was man da wohl alle sieht in der Abstellkammer.
Äh.
Spülmittel, Haarwaschmittel.
Staubsauger.
Aber das sieht man gar nicht.
Man sieht eh nur den 3D Drucker wenn ich das richtig eingestellt habe.
Reload.
So jetzt gucken wir mal ob die Webcam funktioniert.
Triangulieren Wandschalen.
Hat die Abstellkammer da eine Position.
Was ich schon alles geleakt habe.
Hier meine Hofeinfahrt.
So da sind wir.
Okay Control. Mal gucken ob die Webcam geht.
Es könnte sein dass die Webcam geht.
Aber ich das Licht nicht an habe.
Ich muss mal gucken ob ich das Licht angemacht habe.
Da seht ihr.
Guckt mal da.
Da kann ich das Licht sogar remote ein und ausschalten.
Aber gerade nicht.
Ne.
Das kann ich nicht ein und ausschalten.
Das hat kein Shelly die abstellt.
Normalerweise brauche ich das nicht.
Aber ihr werdet es gleich sehen.
Ich brauche das Licht gar nicht wirklich.
Mein 3D Drucker hat hier unten ein Licht dran.
Ihr werdet es gleich sehen.
Wenn wir mal einen Demodruck machen.
Wir müssen das Ding eh noch ordentlich leveln.
Weil das Bett ist total verstellt.
Das ist kacke.
So.
Als erstes installieren wir nochmal ein Plugin.
Und zwar.
Installieren wir.
Wo ist mein Plugin Manager.
Wir installieren hier Webcam Fullscreen.
Da sieht man nämlich ein bisschen mehr.
Von der Webcam.
Looten und leveln.
Ja looten je nach dem.
Manchmal geht der Druck echt in die Hose.
Aber mit leveln.
Ist gemeint.
Dass das Druckbett gerade eingestellt wird.
So.
Restart now.
Ok wir haben Plugin installiert.
Wir müssen Restarten.
Warum?
Auch immer das notwendig ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich nur um sicher zu gehen.
Das es funktioniert.
Ne wie gesagt kein Shelly in der Abstellkammer.
Aber ich brauche da auch keinen Shelly in der Abstellkammer.
Baue ich aber wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein.
Ich habe ja noch genug.
Weil eigentlich will ich da gar kein Licht.
Also ich habe nämlich was die Webcam anbelangt.
Entweder mache ich da eine richtige Kamera mit Night Vision hin.
Ich habe nämlich noch ne.
Am Start.
Ach ich habe es euch ja gerade erzählt.
Ich habe mir 5 Kameras gekauft neue.
Bei Amazon.
Aber bevor jetzt wieder irgendjemand ankommt und sagt.
Max schmeißt das Geld nicht so zum Fenster raus.
Ähm.
Die behalte ich nicht alle.
Es ist nur unglaublich schwierig rauszukriegen.
Was welche Kamera kann.
Gerade von den Chinesen.
Weil da kaum was gescheites bei steht.
Ich habe mir ein paar Kameras bestellt.
Ich habe mir hier die bestellt.
Die hat aber kein WLAN das weiß ich.
Aber die hat eine ziemlich gute Night Vision.
Und die ist ziemlich klein.
Vielleicht verwende ich die nämlich für einen 3D Drucker.
Shelly ist ein Relay für.
Unterputz Relay.
Da kannst du Licht mit ein- und ausschalten.
Und der Lichtschalter funktioniert weiterhin.
So ähm.
Also ich habe mir die Kamera gekauft.
Dann habe ich mir eine.
Habe ich vorher nicht mal gewusst.
Dass dieser Hersteller überhaupt existiert.
Äh.
Richtig billiges Kack Ding.
Ähm.
Ob das Ding.
Irgendwo bestellt.
Das ist für mich mega schlecht.
Dann habe ich noch ähm.
Eine.
Die bestellt und da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das werden wir uns nämlich im Stream zusammen angucken.
Die hat nämlich eine Custom Firmware.
Für die hier.
Hallo Kyokun.
Für die China Cam hier.
Gibt es eine Custom Firmware.
Die probieren wir dann demnächst im Stream aus.
So das Ding hatte ich mir bestellt.
Das da, das da.
Und dann noch.
Die zwei.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was davon was taugt.
Das wichtige bei Kameras bei mir ist.
Ähm.
Ich habe da ein paar Ansprüche dran.
Die finde ich nicht so hoch sind.
Aber irgendwie schwierig sind.
Weil ich kann nicht so genau verstehen.
Kamera Config über den Web Interface.
Ich will keine China App verwenden.
Die Kamera braucht ein Web Interface.
Auch Initial Config über den Web Interface.
So das nächste ist.
Ich brauche einen RTSP Stream.
Am besten einen RTSP Stream mit ähm.
Sagen wir mal 720p Plus.
Und einen in Low Quali.
Schon mal die Insta Kameras angeschaut.
Ja viel zu fett und viel zu alt.
Von dem was drin ist.
Und viel zu teuer für das finde ich.
Ähm.
Und am liebsten das ganze über WLAN.
Da war nämlich.
Da bin ich auf Twitter Leute.
Da bin ich wieder ausgeflippt.
Innerlich.
Weil es die Leute wieder nicht gecheckt haben.
Und für drinnen reicht keine Kamera mit Raspberry Pi.
Doch aber die ist ja auch nicht für drinnen.
Die ist ja für außen.
Outdoor.
Regen.
Für innen würde eine Raspberry Pi Kamera reichen.
Aber für innen habe ich ja noch meine ollen.
Ähm.
Wisecams mit Custom Firma.
Die gehen ja wunderbar.
Also hier das war.
Wo habe ich das gepostet mit der Kamera.
Also ich habe ja gestern geschrieben.
Ich suche eine WLAN Outdoor Überwachungskamera.
Strom über USB oder 12 Volt.
Mindestens 720p Stream über RTSP.
Und Web Interface für die Config.
Pan Tilt wäre auch nicht verkehrt.
Gut hat davon jetzt keiner.
Muss aber auch nicht unbedingt sein.
So und was antworten die Leute drauf.
Die meisten waren nicht alle schlecht.
Die meisten waren sogar gut.
Habe ich mir eine bestellt.
Ähm.
Erste Antwort ist hier.
Irgendwas mit das sie kein WLAN hat.
So.
Das habe ich gegoogelt.
Das ist mega fett das Ding.
So und das ist auch geil.
Das finde ich immer geil.
Das wenn du was auf Twitter postest.
Du hast immer so Belehrungsleute am Start.
Das vierte Wort passt nicht mit dem sechsten Wort zusammen.
Was weiß ich denn.
Wieso WLAN.
Wenn LAN viel besser und stabiler ist.
Außerdem würde das nur unnötig deinen WLAN Traffic zumüllen.
Außerdem.
Stichwort PoE.
Ok.
Da möchte sich einer wahnsinnig schlau vorkommen.
Als wäre ich nicht selbst auf die Idee gekommen.
Die Kamera über PoE zu betreiben.
Natürlich bin ich auf die Idee gekommen.
Das ist das erste was einem einfällt.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Das die Stelle an die die Kamera kommt.
Kein Netzwerkkabel hat.
Da ist kein Netzwerkkabel.
Passive Exile genau.
Da ist halt kein Netzwerkkabel.
Was soll ich denn machen.
Soll ich.
Soll ich PoE über Luft machen oder wie.
Wenn da ein Netzwerkkabel wäre.
Würde ich PoE machen.
Aber da ist kein Netzwerkkabel.
Not even close Netzwerkkabel.
Ja erstmal Löcher in die Wand machen.
Für das Netzwerkkabel.
So ist der hier jetzt fertig.
Ah ja gut.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Mal neu starten.
Jetzt sollte ich nämlich.
Ah guck mal jetzt kann ich die Webcam groß machen.
So.
Und bei der Gelegenheit kann ich auch den Drucker.
Gleich mich mal zum Drucker connecten.
Und gucken ob das funktioniert.
Wir gucken nicht hin Leute.
Wenn wir nicht hingucken geht es schneller.
Ah ist connected.
Gut.
Weil jetzt kann man auch.
Hier ein bisschen mit rum fahren.
Guck jetzt fahren wir den mal ein bisschen rum.
Ui da fährt er.
Oh da klebt noch ein Druck dran.
Und da liegt noch eine.
Ha eine SSD Höhle.
Die habe ich verwendet zum Kamera scharf stellen.
So.
Kann mal rum fahren.
Und jetzt kann man sagen.
Fahr zu Home.
Und dann fährt er zu Home.
Wunderbar.
Ich muss mal kurz rüber den Kram abkratzen der da drauf hängt.
Gleich wieder da.
So.
Jetzt fahr ich nochmal hier vor.
Und jetzt sieht man auch.
Oh.
Ich hab da was vergessen abzumachen.
Moment.
Oh nein hab ich die Hand geleaked.
Handleaked.
Meine Güte.
So.
Jetzt hab ich den ganzen Kram hier mal abgekratzt.
Übrigens das stößt hier oben nicht an.
Das hängt da drüber.
Da passiert nix.
Guckt wenn ich voll hoch fahr.
Das sieht zwar so aus als stößt er an aber das macht nix.
Aber das muss da also.
Diese Auflage sollte da auf jeden Fall weg.
Aber da passiert nix.
So.
Jetzt kann man das hier nämlich groß machen.
Wunderbar.
So was wir jetzt machen müssen bevor wir einen Testdruck fahren.
Ist.
Der Druck von der Kamera sackt ein bisschen.
Und wir können.
Auch mal.
Wie genau kann das Ding drucken.
Was meinst du?
Meinst du genau mit.
Irgendwas mit Millimeter.
Oder meinst du mit genau wie ein 3D Drucker funktioniert.
Also ich werde gleich einen Druck machen.
Da gucken wir zu.
Aber Millimeter.
Also die Öffnung da vorne ist 0,4.
Äh.
Nicht nicht.
Genau das ist.
Also für mein Zeug.
Mit bisschen Gehäuse drucken.
Genug.
Ähm.
Zumindest.
Warte ich gerade mal wieder rum.
Wir müssen erst mal gucken das die Kamera ein bisschen höhere Auflösung bekommt.
Weil ich mein.
Das sieht kacke aus.
Und vielleicht können wir die Exposure Time auch ein bisschen hoch stellen.
Das das Licht.
Bisschen heller wird.
Aber ihr werdet gleich sehen.
Wenn das Ding anfängt zu drucken wird es hell.
Ich habe einen Drucker gemoddet.
Vor einer Weile schon.
Ähm.
Mit einem Licht.
Ich habe irgendwas von Aliens getwittert.
Irgendwas mit Aliens habe ich getwittert.
Drucker.
Ah hier.
Ah UFO habe ich geschrieben.
Genau.
So sieht das.
Ich habe hier am 3D Drucker unten so einen LED Ring dran.
Das das.
Die Sache schön hell macht.
Leider ist der Ring.
Ein bisschen zu hell.
So das es spiegelt an der Platte unten drunter.
Oh nein das ist keine Kloschüssel in klein.
Die ich hier ausgedruckt habe.
Gut jetzt stellen wir erst mal die Kamera ein bisschen hoch.
Das ist ein bisschen.
Oh.
Moment.
Steht in der Boot Config.
Steht da auch mein WLAN drin?
Ne ok steht nicht drin.
Alles klar dann kann ich wieder anmachen.
Man weiß ja nie.
So ähm.
Der hat hier standardmäßig 10 FPS als Option.
10 FPS für eine 3D Druckerkamera ist ok.
Aber.
Man kann die Auflösung ein bisschen hoch stellen.
Dazu müssen wir uns aber.
What?
Ih.
Ih wer macht denn sowas?
Habt ihr es gesehen Leute?
Wer macht denn sowas?
Das ist ja.
Das ist ja nahezu Gotteslästerung.
Wer hat es erkannt?
Ok wahrscheinlich ist es keine Auflösung.
Maus Support im Vim.
Wer macht denn standardmäßig.
Vim Maus Support an?
Ah.
Set Maus.
Erst mal Maus Support weg.
Dann kann man das Ding ordentlich bedienen.
Ja Maus Support im Vim ist kacke.
Da kannst du nichts kopieren und nichts anklicken im Terminal.
Dann markiert er das im Vim.
Und das bringt dir überhaupt nichts.
So hier stehen nämlich irgendwelche Options.
Die man benutzen kann.
Also wir wollen die Auflösung höher stellen.
Das heißt.
Raspberry Cam.
Framerate ist.
10.
Das ist ok.
Also minus X.
Machen wir 720.
Ne.
1080.
Und Y.
Was mache ich denn für einen Scheiß.
X ist 280.
Ähm.
Nein.
Warte mal.
XY.
Und X ist.
720.
Wie rum ist das jetzt?
Warte mal.
X ist.
Weite.
So rum.
720.
So rum ist richtig.
Was können wir sonst noch schön einstellen.
Exposure Mode.
Nacht.
BR.
Die Kamera sackt ein bisschen.
Die ich da dran habe.
Ähm.
Wir machen mal.
Wir machen mal die Brightness ein bisschen höher.
Auf 55.
Das ist ein bisschen mehr als Default.
Ich glaube Default ist 50 oder so.
So und jetzt ist die Frage.
Ob wir Exposure ein bisschen hochstellen können.
Dass es mehr Licht abkriegt pro Bild.
Die Sache ist aber die.
Ich glaube da kriegen wir keine 10 FPS mehr hin.
EX Auto.
Ok.
Das sollte eigentlich nichts machen.
Set AWB Mode.
Was ist denn AWB Mode?
Ok nix nix für uns.
Set Image Effekt.
Kann man nicht den Sensor setzen?
Sensor Mode.
Das wäre eigentlich viel wichtiger.
Dass man den Sensor Mode setzen kann.
Da kann man zum Beispiel sagen ob man.
Eher mehr FPS will.
Und dafür kleinere Auflösung.
Na gut.
Wir probieren jetzt erstmal so aus ob das funktioniert.
Ob das Bild jetzt besser aussieht.
Gegen der Auflösung.
Und übrigens man muss neu starten dass das greift.
Achja eine wichtige Sache.
Die man nicht vergessen darf.
Was mich das letzte Mal mega gebetet hat.
Man muss hier oben.
Man darf Kamera nicht auf Auto stehen lassen.
Man muss die Kamera auf die Raspberry Pi Cam umstellen.
Obwohl er die Raspberry Pi automatisch erkennt.
Aber wenn man die Kamera nicht.
Hardcoded auf die Raspberry Pi Cam umstellt.
Dann greift die Option hier unten nicht.
Reboot.
Was auch immer das für eine Logik ist.
Quality Control.
Das können wir hoch machen.
Also ich finde es viel interessanter.
Wie man den.
Den Sensor Mode einstellen kann.
Weil.
Die Kamera die Pi Cam.
Die haben verschiedene.
Ja genau.
Guck die haben verschiedene.
Verschiedene Settings.
Die kannst du einstellen.
Auf Full HD.
Da hast du diese Framerates.
Die kannst du das einstellen.
Da hast du 4 zu 3.
Da kannst du das einstellen.
Das wäre eigentlich das aller wichtigste dabei.
Weil der Default Sensor Mode.
Meistens übelst der Crap ist.
Für das was man machen will.
Na gut gucken wir mal.
Sind wir wieder da.
Wir sind wieder da.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal noch eins machen.
SSH Copy ID.
Da müssen wir nämlich noch einmal unser Passwort eingeben.
Ab jetzt können wir uns ohne Passwort einladen.
So schauen wir mal.
Ob die Webcam Auflösung jetzt besser ist.
Ja.
Wir sind gerade.
Bewegt sich der Drucker oder bewegt sich die Kamera?
Warum bewegt er sich?
MonkaS.
Vielleicht fällt auch die Kamera gleich ab.
Hallo?
Ah. Ich will das hier zu machen.
You got hacked.
Gleich kommt der Jumpscare.
What the fuck?
Ich weiß nicht genau was das da macht.
Ok.
Ich richte mal kurz die Kamera wieder ein bisschen aus.
Kann das sein das es laggt as fuck?
Das ist mega laggt.
Vorhin ging es noch.
Das laggt mega.
So viel Quali.
Das ist ja.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Wir haben ja fast nichts an Quali da gemacht.
Das liegt an X-Auto.
Der Sbarro hat es kaputt gemacht.
Ich sage es liegt an X-Auto.
Ich starte mal neu.
Jetzt geht es bestimmt ein klein flüssiger.
Ich mache mal die Kamera fest.
Ne der Sbarro das konnte ja nur wirklich keiner wissen jetzt.
Schau mal ob das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Oh guck mal ich dab.
Ich habe das Licht ausgemacht.
Man sieht aber das die Kamera an ist.
Weil man sieht das Display vom 3D Drucker.
Null.
Ja die Kamera ist nicht so richtig gut.
Richtig gut fest.
Ob es jetzt genau so viel laggt noch.
Wirklich flüssig ist das nicht.
Ich hätte jetzt aber eigentlich erwartet, dass das flüssiger ist.
Ich würde jetzt auch erwarten, dass das jetzt runterfährt.
Oh, ich meine, da macht ja fast gar nichts.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Kamera leckt.
Da macht einfach nichts.
Wisst ihr was, wir lassen jetzt einfach mal was drucken.
Na doch, die Kamera leckt ein bisschen.
Die Kamera leckt ein bisschen.
Guck mal, so eine Sekunde, hä?
Oder fünf Sekunden.
Warum leckt?
Das ist aber ganz schön lang.
Also, so lang sollte das eigentlich nicht sein.
Und schaut mal, das sind fünf Sekunden Leck.
Warum leckt das so lang?
Viel zu lang, haben wir doch irgendeinen Mist angegeben.
Da kannst du ja gar nicht richtig zugucken.
Gut, beim 3D-Drucken an sich ist das ziemlich wurscht.
Wir machen es die fünf Sekunden nicht aus.
Nö, aber ansonsten kann da eigentlich nicht viel sein.
Vielleicht ist die Auflösung jetzt zu hoch.
Guck mal, also, Klick.
Fünf, ja, fünf Sekunden.
Na gut.
Wir installieren noch.
Das ist ein anderes Plugin.
Ich will nämlich dieses Sidebar-Plugin installieren,
wo man die Kamera an der Seite sieht.
Das da.
So.
Und danach machen wir mal so einen Calibration-Druck.
Wir können mal gucken, wie viel der MJPEG-Streamer braucht,
aber hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich starte now.
Ne, 10 FPS müsste eigentlich relativ flüssig sein.
Dass es so eine Verzögerung hat, ist merkwürdig.
Also, fünf Sekunden ist ganz schön viel.
Ich werde es in Zukunft aber eh nicht so machen.
Ich werde die Webcam weiter ganz normal per WebRTC in meinen Überwachungskamera-Frontend packen.
Und dann ist es auch schnell.
Aber es ist halt praktisch, wenn man die Webcam hier drinne hat.
Dann kann man nämlich hier direkt, während man Settings macht, zugucken.
So, reload.
Weil jetzt haben wir nämlich hier oben auch noch eine Webcam.
Das ist relativ...
...nützlich.
Weil sonst müsste man immer in Control sein.
Gut, also, wir 3D-Drucken mal was.
Wir 3D-Drucken mal dieses Calibration-Ding, was ich vorher auch gedruckt habe.
Und daran wird man nämlich sehen, wie schlecht...
What the fuck?
...und auch unterschiedlich schnell der Kram.
So, da wird man zumindest mal sehen,
wie schlecht das Bett vom 3D-Drucker ausgerichtet ist.
By the way, der ist doch verkehrt.
Hier ist das Dism...
Ach nee, er ist rechts oben.
Okay, nee, das passt.
Okay, also.
Wir nehmen das Ding hier.
Das habe ich nämlich das letzte Mal auch genommen.
Genau.
Das druckt so kleine Quadrate auf das Druckbett.
Und da kann man dann erkennen, ob man sein Druckbett richtig ausgerichtet hat.
Also sprich, hier unten drunter, also das da.
Ich versuche es jetzt mal hochzufahren.
Was mit Längs.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt richtig ausgerichtet habe.
Also sprich, hier unten drunter, also das da.
Ich versuche es jetzt mal hochzufahren.
Was mit Leck gar nicht so einfach ist.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Sehr gut.
Das Ding hier, wenn das nicht gerade...
Oh, das leckt aber huge, Alter.
So krass am lecken.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Ich probier das mal was aus.
Ich stell das jetzt nochmal kurz zurück.
Auf Default.
Gucken, ob das daran irgendwie was mit zu tun hat.
Ja, die Vorschau ist auch noch schneller gewesen.
Ist komisch, ne?
Ich lad mir mal das Kalibrierungsding runter.
Genau, also Sinn und Zweck der Sache ist,
dass man das Muster schön sieht
und dass nichts zu dick
beziehungsweise nichts
zu dünn ist.
Also sprich, dass der Druckkopf
nicht schleift und dass
das Muster keine Lücken hat. So, und dann ist es gut.
Und dann werdet ihr mal sehen, wie schlecht mein Bett
eingestellt ist.
Ihr habt es ja vorhin schon kurz gesehen.
Thingiverse, wer es nicht kennt, ist übrigens
eine super Seite für 3D Drucker
Fans.
Also da findet man zu allen möglichen Sachen
fertige Gehäuse, fertige Projekte, sonst was.
Das hier ist eigentlich
ganz nützlich zum
Kalibrieren. Zumindest habe ich das
das letzte Mal auch mitgemacht.
Was?
Ich soll mein... Ernsthaft?
Warum soll ich mein...
Gut, da gucken wir uns
die Werbung von denen an.
Okay.
Nach 5 Stunden konnte ich wie ein gebürtiger Brite sprechen.
Ah, das ist auch noch
äußerst seriöse Werbung. Alles klar.
Nach 5 Stunden
perfekt englisch native.
Alles klar, natürlich.
Was sonst?
So, jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal noch ein Programm installieren.
Mit dem man die ganzen
Sachen für einen 3D Drucker aufbereiten kann.
Weil es ist so, ein 3D Drucker
der kann nur
quasi
Anweisungen
für seinen Druckkopf
setzen. Ein 3D Drucker hat keine Ahnung
von irgendwelchen 3D Models oder sowas.
Dementsprechend
braucht man erst ein Programm, was
aus den 3D Models
Anweisungen für den 3D Drucker macht.
Und das machen wir hiermit.
Und es gibt auch ein Plugin, dass man
das direkt mit Octopie verbinden kann.
Direkt hier aus dem Slicer rausdrucken
kann. So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal
unseren Drucker hinzufügen. Den da.
Jawohl. Next.
Finish. Gut.
So, jetzt öffnen wir den
Kram hier mal runter. Ich habe echt
irgendwelche Schriftdaten nicht installiert. Das sieht ja
grausam aus. Paper please.
Wo habe ich es runtergeladen?
Wohin habe ich das runtergeladen? Max Downloads.
So, alles gut.
Max. Download.
Hä? Wo ist
mein Download? Achso, ich muss
den Kram erstmal entpacken.
Was? Habe ich kein Unzip installiert?
Ernsthaft nicht?
Ist ja nichts drauf hier.
Ist ja...
Ist ja armselig.
So, jetzt
aber.
Files. Da ist
es. Gut.
So. Huge 3D Model.
Ich weiß. Fünf kleine
Quadrate.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, dass wir
die Dicke und so richtig eingestellt
haben.
02.
Das passt alles.
Alles gut. Slice.
So, und da kommen jetzt die Daten raus,
die man zum 3D-Drucker schicken kann.
Speichern wir das Ganze. Gehen wir in
Octoprint. Und das ist jetzt halt der Riesenvorteil,
wenn man Octoprint verwendet. Normalerweise
müsste man den Kram jetzt auf die, ähm,
eine SD-Karte
packen, zum 3D-Drucker laufen,
SD-Karte reinschieben und drucken. Und dann
würde man... Hätte man überhaupt keine Übersicht.
So, was man jetzt machen kann, ist
den Kram...
Warum muss
ich eigentlich alles fünfmal machen gerade?
So.
Jetzt kann man nämlich den Kram hier hochladen.
Dann erkennt er das.
Dann kann man das anklicken. Und dann sagt er, okay,
ich brauch... Achso, erstmal muss ich mich connecten zum Drucker.
Ja, stimmt.
Track & Drop geht. Hab ich nicht dran gedacht.
Ja. Wie gesagt, ich hab lange
nichts mehr gedruckt.
So, dann klickt man das an.
Wenn er irgendwann mal den Drucker erkennt hat, drei Stunden später.
Äh,
manchmal failt das übrigens.
Und dann muss man es nochmal machen und dann geht's.
So,
von 20 Mal geht das irgendwie kaputt.
Dann muss man einfach disconnecten
und nochmal connecten. Dann ist gut.
Jetzt sollte er
es aber langsam mal gecheckt haben.
Dass er sich mit dem 3D-Drucker verbindet.
Ansonsten, wenn er es nicht
gecheckt hat, machen wir die
Windows-Taktik. Wir rebooten einfach.
Ah, jetzt hat er es gecheckt. Okay.
Ist verbunden.
Ähm, und
nu... Achso, wir haben jetzt glaube ich
auch wieder die kleinere Auflösung hier, ne?
Ist das jetzt schneller mit der
kleineren Auflösung?
Äh,
what the fuck ist mit dem...
Was hat der mit der Druckerverbindung?
Was hat der für
Schmerzen?
Ich hab jetzt die Tür zu. Normalerweise hört man, wenn er sich
verbindet. Der macht dann
düt, düt, düt.
Ich starte jetzt mal den Raspberry Pi neu. Wenn das nichts hilft,
dann, äh,
dann starte ich den
3D-Drucker neu.
Der für Schmerzen.
Never
happened before.
Schauen wir mal, wann das Ding wieder da ist.
Ansonsten ist das zumindest
die Verbindung eigentlich ziemlich zuverlässig.
Klickst du drauf und es geht.
Ist gut.
Firefox. Alles klar.
Machen wir es einfach ohne HTTPS.
She baited.
You got
she baited.
Wer braucht HTTPS?
Echt? Kann man das ausschalten? Das ist
praktisch.
So. Okay. Mal gucken, ob das Connecten jetzt funktioniert.
Achtung.
Der hat
irgendeinen Schlag gerade.
Ah. Jetzt hat er sich verbunden.
Okay.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt ein bisschen
leckfreier geht.
Ah, guck mal. Oh.
Oh. Leute, die Kamera rutscht.
Die Kamera ist übelst
dumm oben hin gepappt.
Ah.
Ich muss die Kamera festmachen.
Ja, ja. Das ist die Standard.
Das Ding ist komplett Standard.
Alter. Kamera.
Fuck mich nicht ab.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich da meine Unify-Kamera
das nächste Mal hinhänge.
Oh. Die bewegt sich wieder.
Ich klebe es gleich fest.
Okay.
Wir hoffen jetzt mal einfach, dass es so bleibt.
Und wir starten mal
den Druck. Okay.
Die Kamera ist übrigens, by the way,
mittlerweile auch ein bisschen schepp.
So. Druck. Druck.
Zack.
Er meint 4 Minuten. Ich kann euch sagen,
es wird ein bisschen länger dauern. Print.
So. Und was
jetzt auch in Octoprint
bzw. Octopark ganz nützlich ist,
die Anzeige.
Du siehst, wann er anfängt zu drucken.
Also sprich, Target Temperature
und
Bed Temperature. Also sprich,
das ist das dort, worauf er druckt.
Das ist die Temperatur vom Druckkopf.
Und erst, wenn das
oben ist, fängt er halt an zu drucken.
Deswegen ist allein schon die Printzeit hier immer
übelstes Debate. Das kann überhaupt nicht
stimmen. Das dauert
jetzt 1-2 Minuten zum Aufheizen.
Weshalb
die Printtime schon mal gar nicht hinkommt.
So.
Und jetzt könnt ihr gleich sehen, wie schlecht
mein Bett gelevelt ist.
So in 5 Stunden.
Wenn er
aufgeheizt hat. Ich glaube, der fängt erstmal
an und heizt das Druckbett auf und dann
heizt er den Druckkopf aus.
Dass er das Druckbett aufheizt, ist
so, ist wirklich praktisch, weil
wenn
der, diese, wie nennt sich das?
Dieses Filament. Wenn das auf
das Druckbett kommt und das Druckbett ist warm,
dann klebt das extrem
fest.
Wenn das Druckbett kalt ist,
dann geht das ab. Also das heißt, solange
das Druckbett warm ist,
pappt die Unterlage richtig
fest. Stimmt
die Printtime? Die Printtime hier
stimmt nicht, aber es gibt nen Plugin, was ne deutlich
bessere Printtime-Berechnung hat.
Die Standard-Printtime-Berechnung
ist...
Naja.
Stimmt mal, mal stimmt's nicht.
Äh, Clocks HD ist das dieses Auto-Level-Ding.
Moin Patrick.
Wir warten, bis der 3D-Drucker
anfängt zu drucken.
So, jetzt sollte eigentlich die
Temperatur gleich hochgehen.
Guck dir, zack.
Jetzt geht die Temperatur vom Druckkopf
hoch.
Und dann...
Ne, wie gesagt, auch die Printtime, wenn die Temps
stimmen, ist nicht so ganz richtig.
Es gibt nen Plugin, was das deutlich besser berechnet,
die Printtime. Ah, guck mal, habt ihr gesehen?
Das Licht ist angegangen.
Das ist das, was ich da mal dran gemoddet hatte.
Ähm,
wenn der Strom angeht, hier oben,
hier ist ja ein Lüfter drin.
Und er macht den Lüfter an ab ner gewissen Temperatur.
Hier so, bei, keine Ahnung,
bei 120 Grad.
Bei 120 Grad geht der Lüfter an.
Wenn der Lüfter angeht, geht auch der LED-Ring an.
Man sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen das Problem
da dran, der LED-Ring ist
eigentlich viel, viel zu hell.
Der spiegelt erst, fuck,
das müsste ich, müsste ich die ganze Ecke,
da müsste ich irgendwie noch irgendwas zum Dimmen dran machen
oder so. Aber das war das erste,
was ich mit dem 3D-Drucker damals gemacht hab.
Ich hab mir nen Teil 3D druckt,
um meinen
3D-Drucker zu modden.
Welchen 3D-Drucker hast du? Ein Anycubic
i3 Mega S.
Hab ich mir anfangs
in den letzten Jahres geholt und ich hab halt kaum
was mit gedruckt und ich hab festgestellt,
dass der wohl vor einem halben Jahr oder so
mein Octopar schon abgekackt ist und ich gar nichts mehr drucken konnte.
Deswegen würd ich das jetzt grad wieder neu installieren.
i3 Omega.
i3 Monka S.
So, und wenn der jetzt irgendwann mal die
Temperatur erreicht hat, was jetzt übrigens soweit
ist gleich,
bei 200 Grad, ihr werdet sehen, bei 200 Grad
liegt der los.
So.
Gleich, gleich geht's los.
Und da druckt er jetzt dieses Kalibrierungs-Ding.
Dann seht ihr, wie schlecht mein Bett gelevelt ist.
Ah, auf geht's!
Ups.
Auf geht's!
Das ist by the way
das Kabel von der Kamera, glaub ich, oder?
Das Kabel von der Kamera?
Das wäre nicht gut, wenn
das Kabel von der Kamera da hängt, das reißt gleich ab.
Es bewegt sich.
So.
Jetzt spritzt er erstmal
ne Runde drumherum,
um, äh,
Filament ein bisschen zu reinigen.
Das kann man übrigens ausstellen, dass der einmal den 3D-Druck
umfährt. Oder zwei, drei, ich glaub, der
umfährt den 3D-Druck sogar zwei, dreimal.
Das ist einfach, dass da
die Düse gereinigt ist.
Aber der Strahler ist doch ganz nützlich, ne?
Man erkennt sogar ein bissl mehr, als
wenn das da dran strahlt.
Wobei es halt viel zu hell ist.
So, jetzt ist er,
jetzt hat er dreimal drumherum gesprayt.
Und jetzt fängt er gleich an.
Eigentlich voll die
Materialverschwendung bei solcher Strecke.
So, jetzt fängt er an.
So, und er macht nichts anderes
wie fünf kleine Quadrate drucken.
Und die kann man sich danach angucken
und daran sieht man, äh,
wie gut das Bett gelevelt ist.
Und ihr werdet sehen, es ist ganz, ganz grausam gelevelt
bei mir.
Also im Optimalfall sollte das Ganze so aussehen
am Ende.
So sollten die Quadrate aussehen.
Er hat noch ein bisschen Muster drauf.
Bei mir sind die Quadrate eher
teils so aus
und teils so.
Ihr werdet es
gleich sehen.
Mal kurz Fullscreen.
Seht ihr, was ich lustig finde?
Dass die Vorschau hier mehr ruckelt, als die
andere Vorschau. Sehr merkwürdig.
Guckt mal hier.
Das hängt
schon voll in Fetzen hier oben.
Seht ihr es?
Es hängt schon
voll in Fetzen. Das sieht
eher so aus hier.
Anstatt so.
Also da ist der Abstand zu groß.
In der Mitte ist es, in der Mitte ist es gut.
Ups. In der Mitte, in der Mitte
ist es ganz gut.
Was ist das für ein blauer Balken?
Ich glaube, das ist der Druckfortschritt.
Wie weit er ist.
Der denkt, er ist gleich fertig, aber das ist
G-Bait. Der muss noch
zwei Stück drucken. Aber, wie gesagt,
so ungefähr kommt es hin.
Ja, der ist auch
viel zu, wobei das könnte,
der rechts unten könnte ganz gut sein.
Und man sieht, der Strahler ist viel
zu hell, wenn er zu nah dran ist. Da siehst du nichts.
So, und jetzt müsste er noch hochfahren,
noch ein Dreieck, äh, noch ein Viereck machen.
Und dann kann man sich den Kram mal angucken.
Blub.
Guckt hier, hier siehst du schon richtig die Lücken drinnen.
Also das ist nichts.
Das Bett muss ich morgen mal in Ruhe
noch einstellen. Das ist
übrigens auch ein Vorteil, wenn man sich einen teureren 3D-Drucker
kauft. Die machen
das automatisch. Oder zumindest
automatisch den Abstand messen.
Dass das
das ausgleicht. Ich muss hier, guck hier unten sind
so Rädchen dran. Ich kann hier
unten an den Rädchen drehen und halt
einstellen, dass das Bett gerade ist.
Ja.
So, jetzt müsste er fertig sein angeblich.
Guck mal, der ist sogar fertig.
Das war relativ akkurat.
Das hier war viel zu nah dran. Das in der Mitte
ist glaube ich ganz okay. So,
fertig gedruckt. Ne, ich will da
nichts modden, großartig.
So, und jetzt geht er gleich wieder aus.
Sobald die Temperatur runtergeht.
Also, die Temperatur fällt jetzt.
Aktuell kann ich das gar nicht abmachen.
Also, das ist so
bombenfest.
Hängt das noch hier unten an der Unterlage dran.
Das funktioniert nicht. Ich muss jetzt erstmal
warten, bis das abgekühlt ist. Sonst kann ich es nicht abmachen.
Also, das ist nicht verflüssig.
Also, das ist sofort hart,
sobald das da drauf ist. Aber
es klebt hart as fuck
an der Unterlage. Und erst, wenn
das hier wieder runterfällt, so auf
keine Ahnung, 30 Grad oder so, erst
dann kriegt man das überhaupt von der Unterlage ab. Bis jetzt.
Jetzt kannst du das knicken.
Genau, jetzt wo der gerade hier am
ausgehen ist. Ein anderes Plugin, was
ich unbedingt noch ausprobieren wollte, ist das
hier.
Print Time Genius.
Der ist wohl deutlich genauer,
was Druckzeiten
berechnen anbelangt.
Übrigens, wer sich fragt,
wie lange es dauert, was richtiges zu
drucken.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal kurz aus.
So ungefähr, weil
hier, der hat auch nur ungefähr
eine Vorschau, wie lange das ganze dauert.
Und zwar, wenn ich mir jetzt mal ein Gehäuse
raussuche für mein ESP32.
Irgendwas, was passt.
Übrigens, das ist das Falsche.
Das ist das Richtige.
Oh, die Seite ist ja wieder
Massive High Speed hier.
So, wenn man jetzt irgendwie sowas nimmt,
was übrigens extrem hässlich bei dem
ausgedruckt aussieht, aber ich glaube, das ist
ganz nett.
Ähm, ich brauch
ja, das da oben lasse ich
weg für die Antenne. Dann nehmen wir als Beispiel
das Gehäuse.
Ich muss den Adblock wieder ausmachen.
Weiß jemand aus dem Kopf,
wie diese andere Seite hieß?
Es gab noch eine
zweite.
Dies verlängert den Geschlechtsakt
und steigert Erlebnisse. Sie werden auch
die anspruchsvollsten Frauen befriedigen
können. Sehen. Nein.
Nicht Sehen.
Monkatos Sehen.
Höchst seriöse Werbung, für die ich hier
meinen Adblocker ausschalten soll, wie es aussieht.
Erinnert mich an den Fail damals.
Nein, da konnte ich ja nichts für.
My Mini Factory?
War das das?
Meine ich, das könnte
das tatsächlich
gewesen sein.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob
es die Seite war, die ich meine.
Na zumindest, wir öffnen das jetzt mal.
Achso, ich muss das mal anzippen.
Anzip.
Wir öffnen das mal, damit wir sehen, die
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Anzip.
Es.
Es. Es.
Entpacken.
So.
Wir öffnen das Ganze jetzt mal.
Und dann
gucken wir mal.
Übrigens, ich sollte das erstmal löschen.
So.
Wir drucken das mal.
Nur das nebeneinander
drucken braucht meistens viel zu lang.
Man konnte doch irgendwie sagen,
dass er das ordentlich
anordnen soll.
Ging das nochmal?
Ja, so.
Genau.
Wenn man jetzt sagt Slice,
braucht der...
Okay, das stimmt nicht ganz.
Ich würde eher sagen,
übrigens, wenn man auf 0,3 hochgeht,
also sprich, dass er das gröber druckt,
ist er schneller.
Aber es ist halt nicht so fein.
Also sprich,
wenn ich das jetzt nehme und sage,
okay, fang mal an zu drucken.
Infill braucht man hier
nicht wirklich großartig,
weil ich meine, das ist halt nichts zum Infillen.
Dann ist er jetzt
der Meinung, er braucht
52 Min... Was macht denn Preview?
So, und
ich würde mal sagen,
52 Minuten ist ein bisschen
Cheap Aid. Wir laden das jetzt mal runter.
Ups.
Äh, Moment.
New Project.
Wir laden das mal runter und gucken dann,
was diese...
dieses Analyse-Ding
sagt, wie lange es
brauchen würde. So, 52 Minuten.
Zack.
Octoprint. Ja, Restart
Now. Da will ich ja wirklich für
alles neu starten, ja.
Ja, Glocks, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich will das Ding
nicht modden großartig. Ich habe mir den
gekauft, erstens, weil er ein guter Preis-Leistungsverhältnis ist
und zweitens, weil er out of the box gut funktioniert.
Hallo?
Ich will das...
Also, 3D-Drucker ist eine Sache,
habe ich mir für ein paar Gehäuse gekauft.
Naja, wenn du da eine größere,
wenn du irgendwelche größeren Sachen dran schraubst
und sowas. Äh, ich habe mir das
gekauft, ein paar Gehäuse auszudrucken. Ich habe da
gar kein großartiges Interesse dran, da rumzubasteln.
Wobei das ja auch schon wieder nicht richtig
stimmt, ne?
Ähm...
Ich habe ja auch diese, diese
LED-Ansicht vorne
dran gemacht.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Laden wir mal hoch und gucken, was
er meint, was das braucht.
So, übrigens, man kann hier analysieren lassen, wie lange
er der Meinung ist, dass das braucht.
Da muss man irgendwie das Plugin hier
Print Time Genus Analyze...
Und jetzt? Äh...
Ne, warte mal.
Wo steht der Kram jetzt nochmal?
Ne, äh...
Ich bin verwirrt.
Estimated Print Time 433...
Achso, ja.
Ja, aber wobei, die Print Time berechnen sollte
eigentlich auch so funktionieren.
So, er ist wieder verbunden.
Oder ist das schon die,
ist das schon die Analyse von diesem Plugin?
Das kann natürlich
auch sein. Ich weiß nicht,
wir gucken, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus. Also,
Upload. Ähm...
Hier, das neue Teil.
Analysieren.
Ich glaube, der
möchte mir sagen, dass er das analysiert hat,
aber, äh, das irgendwie
habe ich, irgendwie habe ich
nicht alle Schriften aninstalliert.
54 Minuten, okay.
So, gehen wir mal in das Plugin.
Und...
Lass sie hier nochmal analysieren.
The fuck?
A fail? Okay, also einmal...
Save.
So.
Er meint, er braucht 54 Minuten. Na dann.
Print. Let's go.
Let's go, printe.
Oh, oh, Moment.
Ich muss das alte abkratzen. Ah, ah, Pause.
Pause. Cancel.
Moment. Ich will abbrechen.
Abbrechen?
Hallo?
Ab...
Lass mich abbrechen. Okay.
Ich darf nicht abbrechen.
Abbrechen ist nicht erlaubt.
Vodka Smoke.
Gut, es kann ja nicht
wirklich was passieren. Also, ich habe jetzt Pause gedrückt.
Ist ja schön und gut, aber ich will, ich will
canceln. Lässt du mich
canceln? Ist wie beim 2D-Drucker.
Ah, ja, okay.
Aha, ich cancel.
Okay, ich kratz das, ich kratz... Ne, jetzt kann ich
das alte nicht abkratzen, weil das Bett so warm ist.
Okay, jetzt muss ich erst mal warten, bis das Bett
wieder runtergefahren ist.
Ah, toll. Vielleicht kriege ich, vielleicht kriege ich
die Kamera auch noch besser dran gepappt.
Auf der anderen Seite, es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn,
wenn ich das jetzt drucke, oder?
Ich meine, das Bett ist so dermaßen schepp.
Das sollte ich erst mal richtig einstellen,
bevor ich mir da jetzt irgendwelche Gehäuse drucke.
Felix sagt Hallo, 4 Monate.
Dankeschön. Excellent Subscription.
Huge. Um nicht zu sagen,
Massive Subscription.
Naja, warte ich jetzt mal, bis das, bis das
Druckbett abgekühlt ist.
Ja, aber Octoprint ist
eine sehr praktische
Software. Ich könnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
perma... Ich muss mal gucken, was mir hier für eine Schriftart fehlt.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Windows-Fonts. Garantiert irgendwelche Windows-Fonts.
Bestimmt, bestimmt irgendwelche.
Irgendwelche
MS-Fonts.
Installieren wir jetzt. Brauche ich
bestimmt.
Ah, MS-Fonts.
Dann das... Guck mal hier, diesen ganzen, ganzen
Windows-Crap.
Geh mal davon aus, dass das irgendwelche... Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was das für Zeichen sind, was der da für Schmerzen hat,
warum die nicht gehen. Zumindest fehlt mir auf jeden Fall
irgendeine Schriftart. Ansonsten müssen wir
jetzt wegen jedem Mist zum 3D-Drucker rüber rennen.
Und...
...der SD-Karte
reinschieben. Was total
beknackt ist, genau. Okay, schauen wir mal,
ob's das war. Firefox.
Hallo.
ReStore. Ah?
Ah, nein. Okay, was, was könnte,
was könnten wir, was könnten mir für Fonts
fehlen? Ich mein, ich kann fucking Emojis
anzeigen lassen in der...
...in der Kommandozeile.
Was könnten mir für Fonts fehlen, dass er das
nicht anzeigen muss? Ist das überhaupt für ein
Zeichen? Sehe ich das denn, was
das ist? Sehe ich das irgendwo?
Oh mein, wo ist das überhaupt?
Vielleicht ist auch das Encoding von der Seite
im Arsch.
Das, das ist, das steht da irgendwie per
JavaScript oder so drin, ha?
Was ist das für Zeichen, die der nicht mag?
Wir gucken mal, was
man im Browser anzeigen kann.
UTF-8 Browser Testpage.
Jawoll.
Wer nicht? Wtf?
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt raus,
was das für ein Zeichen ist?
Aha.
Ja. Star Symbol.
Black Star Symbol.
Unicode 1.1.
Font missing.
Lieblings.
Brauch ich denn da für ein Font?
Ancient Fonts.
Nee, die sind nicht schlecht.
Oh.
Excellent. Yes.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Mindflow 690.
Mal gucken, ob ich mir das jetzt anzeigen
lassen darf. Ah.
Guck mal da.
Ein Stern.
Der Font hat also gefehlt.
Okay. Ja, sieht doch gleich viel
besser aus. Das ist,
das sind so Sachen, dass man sich um so ein
Kram überhaupt kümmern muss. Auf der
anderen Seite, ja gut.
Wer soll es installieren, wenn
nicht ich?
Also es hat keinen Sinn, wenn ich
das andere Ding jetzt drucken, ne? Ich meine,
das, also
erstens muss ich den Kram noch
abkratzen und zweitens muss ich
erst mal das Bett richtig ausrichten,
dass das sinnvoll
ist. Sag mal,
das ist wirklich gut reagieren. Tut das nett, oder?
Das ist alles ein bisschen
rumgefuddelt.
Naja, gut. Zumindest an
sich tut der Kram wieder. Bin ich schon mal ganz froh,
dass das wieder, dass das prinzipiell wieder
geht. Ähm, da kann ich morgen
ein bisschen
Bett leveln und gucken, dass
der Kram hier wieder ordentlich gerade ist.
Und dann druck ich mir mal ein paar Gehäuse.
So Chat, gibt's noch irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen,
die... Ganz wichtig,
dass mir das Windows Defender mitteilt.
Unglaublich wichtig.
Es wäre eigentlich am besten, wenn Windows Defender
die Klappe halten würde und
mich benachrichtigen würde, wenn
was gefährliches
gefunden wurde.
Da würde man eigentlich von ausgehen, dass das reicht.
Aber nicht so unter Windows.
So Leute,
1.12 Uhr.
Ähm,
mal gucken, ob ich morgen am Start bin.
Mal gucken, wie gesagt,
spätestens Sonntag Aufwach-Stream.
Ähm,
war heute vielleicht nicht für jeden
was, aber ich hoffe, es hat euch trotzdem
gefallen.
Und...
Ja, gibt's sonst noch irgendwas wichtiges?
Trinkst du Alkohol? Nein.
Ich hab ein super Ding zum 3D-Trinken gefunden.
Ist das irgendein Glas, oder was?
Zeig mal her.
Was ist denn das?
Ups, ich hab gerade aus Versehen meinen Chat zugemacht.
Chat, falls ihr was geschrieben habt, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Was soll denn das sein?
Was ist das?
Ihr kennt
das überhaupt nicht.
Da schüttelt man oben rein
und dann verteilt's das in alle Gläser.
Aha.
Also quasi exquisite.
Ja, sowas kann man 3D-drucken.
Warum nicht, ne?
Was ich demnächst nochmal
3D-drucken will, ist
ein
Sieb
für unsere Regenrinne.
Aber nicht die große Regenrinne am
Haus, sondern
die kleine Regenrinne über dem
Terrassendach.
Da ist so eine Mini-Regenrinne
oder so ein Mini-Abguss und
Ausfluss-Abguss.
Wie auch immer.
Und da hab ich
aktuell
einen Schneebesen reingesteckt.
Das ein bisschen gefiltert ist.
Und da wollte
ich mir
so ein Sieb
Filter ausdrucken für.
Muss ich mal ausmessen
und gucken, dass es da gut hinpasst.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis morgen, spätestens bis Sonntag.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
Adieu.